foreign
what kind of holes do you see in Jon
Jones game as well
hey
how good is that huh dude what time they
interviewed him and his his throat was
already like shot
take that back I'll take it off dude
yeah take it off dude
there's already a [__] slit in it
show it to your wife right now yeah dude
check that out he starts crying right
away all this in by the way Tiff I told
you you could do better you don't need
him he doesn't have normal ears the
Fruit Roll-Up gummies dude that's like
the Lifesaver gummies is that what you
got in your [__] licorice flavor what
is that [__] smell it that's good
licorice terrible candy dog in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we have the most
Unfaithful man on Earth Nick the ear
yeah he was talking about leaving his
wife he was saying that uh his wife is
ugly he hates her and I'm like you don't
hate her and she is beautiful you don't
deserve her and you're going to hell I
said all those things on the record on
the record baby and here we have Pat the
man are you jacking it again I'm jacking
again
I forgot about that let me ask you
something what was it like how much [__]
came out the first time dude
dude it was thick like ropes like
literally shooting like robes came out
of my dick how long did it take and you
know like usually like when you like if
you come it's like you get like one or
two like night like good spurts and then
it kind of like kind of dribbles out a
little bit dude it was like eight spurts
like eight like four wow wow wow and I
was like oh [__] you think
that's like half a water bottle
yeah I jerked man and I jerked man kind
of bad why because I was like damn I
should have just kept it going and I but
I can't stop I felt no I felt I was good
for a while and then I fell off like I
was like I was way back to my deviant
ways what did you bust to what was the
first thing pornography I don't remember
what it was probably it was very long
though big booty latina [__] yeah it's
usually did you come and then you just
blast it you were in the shower and it
blast you against the wall like this
I can't controlling legs off the ground
I lifted I lifted yeah dude did it feel
weird because you haven't done it in so
long no it it felt amazing it felt so it
felt amazing
and let me tell you something guy it
felt [__] amazing amazing dude it was
so like and sex dude this I recommend
doing it for this too is like like
having sex if you haven't jerked off
even for like a few days like even for
like four or five days is so like
everything is so sensitive it's [__]
Immaculate dude it's fantastic I feel
like guys don't do that because they
don't want to come too fast yeah dude
what are you not sometimes say [__] it
especially if he's running back again
yeah this one's for me this one's for me
and then we'll go 10 give me 10 minutes
it's kind of flattering isn't it for the
lady yeah like oh I came for like two
seconds so it came before you changed
the air around the [__] page you come
especially if you've been in a
relationship for a long time I feel like
that would be flattering you know what I
mean because it's like you guys have
been hooked but then like one day you're
just like like three Strokes in they're
like whoa he loves me still I still got
it that's what she would say to me what
are you gay look at this gay boy yeah
I'm happy for you man I'm glad you
busting nothing like a cake or something
yeah man I but I made it I did make it I
feel like you're back to your old self
yeah I feel a little more stand-up has
gotten worse yeah
I neglect Maya I'm just a terrible
father
um no but the clarity you get is is nice
though I'm not gonna lie from not
jerking off would you do it again I
would do it again for sure well how long
was it I'm not worth it oh third yeah 31
days all of January I know that's great
you know why that's so difficult you
actually did it during the time where
it's the hardest not to jack off when
it's cold oh you're right when it gets
hot it's [__] annoying because it's
just hot you don't jack off it's all
sticky you know you're a deviant dogs
this will look at me like I said
something ridiculous what you mean no I
just mean good all the time
Autumn Fall whatever my whole thing is
like you're not gonna jack off just
because of the weather bro like what's
wrong with you I'm a quitter my bad duck
what if it's hot and sticky it would be
kind of you know what I mean like you're
if you're bundled up cold you're like
Jack one you just kind of like move
around you're like go in the shower dude
where No One's Gonna bother you you lock
the door dude and you just go to town go
to town water not even on a deviant man
you think I'm a deviant bro a little bit
hey be honest many times a week
this past week
was it a bad week it was a bad week
actually it was it was a long slow week
because I'm at the gym all day bro like
I don't got time to go I don't even have
time to eat lunch sometimes I can't tell
you this though straight up honesty been
working out a lot you know you just be
tired man kinda I brought him in wrecked
you'd be tired I made a sleepy sleepy
boy dude this one made me do the you
know that [__] Ab Roller thing oh
yeah that is the devil's work is that
devil's work that is the I have never
been so sore in my life the only reason
why I made you do that is so you stopped
jerking off all the time bro oh let me
tell you something I've been jerked off
in about two weeks now there you go
I am [__] tired that [__] is terrible
it's the one where you're on your knees
right you roll out well it's because the
way I work out at home is not how normal
people should work out okay I definitely
give myself a lot of leeway and then I
see how far they go they basically kiss
the floor when they do that I don't know
you're supposed to do it like that yeah
yeah when you [__] fit [__]
oh no dude I've seen dudes do it just
from their feet like not even on their
knees those guys are [__] you can do
that [__] which I thought oh you're not
supposed to do it but even like how far
you guys go it's like straight to the
floor
we just you know we just want to make
sure we stop jacking off all the time
because it's a real problem I hate it
and then he had us do like 500 reps of
[__] bench for some god-awful reason
it was dude David's talking [__] it
wasn't even that it was so much weight
he put it like eight but eight plates on
there it was crazy I [__] wish bro I
[__] wish I had eight plates on there
but it was only like
a quarter of a weight plate you know
quarter of a plate weight plate quarter
of a weight plate well guys today we're
going to talk about something that I
feel a lot of people ask us to talk
about fight stuff and it's such a niche
topic and I think some people miss it
and if you don't like it hey it's going
to be interesting anyways because you
just witnessed [__] history my guys
history Jon Jones The Man Who
continually beats his wife all the time
just hitting pregnant women over and
over and over abusing steroids comes
back and becomes that heavyweight
champion of the world dog he can get
away with anything it this is the thing
look before we even talk about the fight
I'll tell you one thing I really really
dislike about him I dislike the [__]
nice guy act yeah yeah that's just be a
jerk off we all know you're a jerk off
yeah that's that's why I like Izzy's
Izzy's Izzy does seem like a cool guy
but Izzy doesn't try to act like he's
like cocky he's flamboyant and you're
like damn he's dope he talks [__] paints
his nails if Jon Jones was just like
yeah I'm kind of an [__] you we would
all respect him a lot more but acting
like the good Christian guy who like
prays for the other dude like when he
clearly is like [__] all these crazy
[__] on the side and like getting the
wild stuff like dude you're clearly not
that guy we all know it you know like
and it's just it's very sociopathic it's
very weird so he comes out obviously
like you could tell when somebody's very
disingenuous when they're talking on the
mic right and I'm not talking about I'm
not judging him about his faith in his
religion but it seems like he's putting
on an act almost just to get under
people's skin so he's doing it on
purpose almost right so he goes I just
want to say thank my Lord and Savior and
then cut to 10 minutes later Francis
said God it was a big old [__] I even
mention God in the same [__] breath
right there's a weird thing that he's
doing sure yeah but nobody thought that
I don't think anybody thought that he
was going to win in the fashion that he
did it was very shocking I didn't think
he was gonna win that easy I I
definitely thought like Sarah gone I I
thought it was going to be way more
competitive 100 I thought surrogon
wrestling is not the best so I was like
okay well Jon Jones has the advantage
there but the just the size just the
fact that he's moving up I was like this
should be somewhat competitive and he
[__] ran through him like nothing
dude John Jones is a true heavyweight in
that octagon he looked bigger than Cyril
he was massive which is very weird
because guys were rubbing together too
bro you saw them thighs that boy fat
everyone makes fun of his calves but
it's his thoughts it's the thighs it's
the butt and the thighs the thighs that
boy fat dude he came in fat yeah he was
thick I was surprised I thought he was
gonna be jacked like a little ripped he
absolutely was not he came in big Triple
C dick
if you guys didn't watch the fight
basically what happened that fight was
about two minutes long what a bummer huh
yeah fans uh Cyril gone is a French
kickboxer very [__] good right ground
game not so great but you know good
enough where he'll survive but Jon Jones
is a different Beast he basically
[__] chokes this [__] out in
two minutes and cereal gone is probably
one of the better heavyweight prospects
in the heavyweight division like you put
that fool in any other division in what
other fighting League he'll probably
wreck everybody yeah sure but not Jon
Jones bro it was such a weird thing to
watch it was weird it was and it was
also showed how strong he is because
like yeah he was able to manhandle him
like that's a bit like right I mean his
wrestling technique is way better for
sure but dude just pure strength size
[__] like So Gone is massive yeah dude
John Jones is like Built For Fighting
though yeah how long he is and yeah like
the way he just wraps people up in the
way he his body awareness it's like it's
like so above everyone else like he just
knows how to lay on people make them
just do what he wants the whole time
like he made that [__] look so it was
freaking easy the timing of the takedown
was hurt the way he like slipped the
punch into the takedown was [__]
perfect he just had to [__] reach out
and grab like he he just in boom down
like it was just perfect timing you know
what was interesting too like I didn't
realize how much his power got better
because when he I think he threw like an
overhead or it was a right cross in the
beginning and you heard the thud yeah I
think Cyril was like holy [__] this
guy's [__] strong you know what I
mean because I don't think he was
expecting to feel that type of force
from the light heavyweight yeah and then
when he got hit by that I think that's
when he started dancing across the case
he goes oh I can't even get touched by
him yeah because he'll put my lights out
like that yeah right which was very
[__] weird and I was also weirded out
by how fast he was still yeah Jon Jones
is like just he's so good at fighting
like I know that's like an
understatement but like when you watch
him fight like he's just so comfortable
in fights to a level that I think most
people are not especially when they
fight him like when you seek uh surrogon
waiting in the ring you see Jon Jones
walking out like he looked like he had
no he's excited like he's like oh I
can't [__] wait to beat the [__] out
of this guy and all the fights except
for like Thiago Santos and maybe Dominic
Reyes he he had that look on his face
except for those fights I felt like he
just was like all right dude let's get
this [__] over with but even then he's
like yeah I'll I'll put it on the fourth
fifth round and still beat you you know
but like every time he fights he's just
like his awareness his IQ it's like he
loves hurting people yeah that's why
he's so badly he's [__] crazy oh he's
not I think like the weird thing about
him too is like
so they had this um
uh ESPN had
four people who used who fought me was
uh Anthony Lionheart Smith it was
Dominic Reyes with that poor boy uh DC
and also Rashad Evans and they all were
discussing Jon Jones and one of the
things that DC brought up which I
thought this is what I love about Daniel
Cormier he's not afraid to ask the tough
questions so he asked them he goes how
do you feel about John Joe saying that
in the light heavyweight division when
he fought YouTube that he wasn't really
motivated yeah you know and so the crazy
thing was like Anthony Smith agreed he
goes yeah he just feel it just felt like
he wasn't
present like he wasn't there like he
almost he was fighting as if he was
fighting not to lose and not to kill me
yeah so he was almost playing with his
food he didn't say those exact words but
that's what it sounded like he said that
he was in the Octagon not to lose
instead of before when he was finding
people like Daniel Cormier Rashad Evans
in there to kill them and that's exactly
what he did the only person who didn't
want to believe that was Dominic Reeves
because that's Dominic Reyes his
highlight in his career as the guy who
technically beat Jon Jones is what he
feels like right so I think with Dominic
Reyes too I I did feel that Jon Jones
just didn't care we didn't see the same
Jon Jones right yeah in this fight we
saw that Jon Jones where he's like oh
I'm a [__] shark I'm gonna kill this
[__] yeah right and he destroyed
him just like how he said he would he
goes he has holes in this game
um his his wrestling his takedown
defense everything is terrible I'ma show
you how easy it's going to be and who
the [__] does it like that yeah that's
wild that was wild you hear a jail son
and talk about it yeah it's really funny
it's sick because he he always got beef
with Jon Jones naturally right because
they they fought he lost him already but
he goes I have to crash and burn
anything that Jon Jones is going to do
so I have to get ahead of this and say
surrogon he goes this is the funniest
stat ever he goes he's one and one in
his last two yeah just to be like cherry
picking you know and he goes he's the
worst Grappler in the heavyweight
division he's not a black belt he's
never had a wrestling fight you're
telling me you're gonna tell me Jon
Jones is gonna have trouble with this
guy he goes Sarah gone absolutely sucks
he's pretty much that's so funny but
then he's kind of right though because
he he exploited the biggest hole in his
game and it was like effortless he had
no answer he had no answer for the
grappling takedowns he got up a little
bit but I feel like it's just because
Jon Jones is like oh I'm gonna just take
you right back down and then [__]
front headlights because I don't grapple
wrestler do Jiu Jitsu right like so when
I was watching that [__] it just looked
like Jon Jones was so heavy on wet
blanket dude he was so heavy on him and
then Cyril God was frozen like when he
was attached to his hip he just wait put
all of his weight on him and he was
trying to gather that wrist and he just
couldn't get his [__] base because
his arms are long enough where he could
[__] know that [__] was so crazy he
was next to his hip and he reached out
and grabbed his wrist yeah which I don't
think most people can do yeah no that's
just not possible yeah his physique is
insane and if you don't wrestle with a
guy who is six four six five however
tall Jon Jones is with the longest
wingspan in the UFC it's gonna like
those problems aren't gonna present
themselves in the training room right so
when you deal with a night of you're
like what the [__] is happening to me
yep and that's what that's what happened
like he just [__] smothered him and
after shirogon got choked out he looked
up like yeah you look confused yeah he
was like why truly a weird just like
complete fighter because he reminds me
of like um honestly like Jordan because
oh man as he gets older his game is
evolving into different things and he's
just excelling at that yeah because look
at it we loved him in his earlier career
because he was like a striking Phenom
like he would always have these weird
openings just these [__] hand traps
like what four or five different
generations of MMA fighters obliterated
every day yeah it made it look easy this
is probably the fourth generation he's
he's ran through yeah right and early in
his career he was doing [__] like out of
a video game like yeah he literally said
he would watch ongbok and then like try
it like that's what he said he was like
I saw it does [__] like I tried it and
it worked this is Tony Jaws fault yeah
yeah this is the reason why you created
a [__] monster in the UFC well he's
only he's going to try to just wrestle
[__] everybody he goes I'm older now I
don't want any damage to my head so he's
just gonna go back to what his original
Pakistani now him and Stipe though is
gonna be interesting on the older side
though but stipe's got the wrestling
base I think sleep is too small for him
am I the only one that thinks he just
smashes through steepe I mean I could
see it I I it's definitely possible it
would just be interesting to see him go
up against the guy who could actually I
would like to see Steve egg at the W
yeah like who doesn't like the only
reason why I don't think steepe is going
to win is because I believe so Daniel
Cormier knocked his ass out the second
fight Daniel Cormier could have easily
won yeah but he was he got he got his
ego went up and he wanted his ass out
which is really really dumb and I think
Daniel Cormier is gonna [__] that's
gonna stick with him for the rest of his
life because he could have beat him
twice in a row yeah right uh and on top
of that the third fight even though
Stipe won very decisively it was still
competitive with Daniel Cormier and
that's a man who [__] John Joe's beat
the [__] out of and I know MMA math
doesn't work that way but sometimes it
does but Jon Jones it does with Jon
Jones I I really think it does yeah and
there's the age Gap too Stipe has been
out of the ring for a very long time and
steepe's a lot older and he didn't look
that great against nganu either and I
don't think that angana would have done
anything to Jon Jones you're thinking
has a chance against Jon Jones no I
don't think he has a chance at all
especially because I think the biggest
factor that I was worried about was how
Jon Jones would deal with uh and ganu's
power but I don't think Jon Jones would
ever give inganu space to even throw
anything yeah he's right in his [__]
and face everybody's so scared of
Mangano that they're right within his
reach yeah right so that distance [__]
because his arms are so [__] long
yeah Jon Jones is not going to allow him
to just [__] start throwing that's
his game that's that's that he wants him
to throw because he wants to close that
[__] distance down so that's true and
ganu is a like out of the heavyweight so
I think the most massive like I think he
cuts doesn't he like have to cut down to
265. I think so and the way he fought
stipa he was patient when he fought him
the third time but you're right I mean
Jon Jones probably would put the
pressure on him try to take him down
immediately I don't think there's anyone
in the heavyweight division that's gonna
mess with Josh this dude is gonna get
away she's smarter oh dude like he's
just he's he's so beyond everybody else
and he has that skill set of like a
smaller guy at that weight class and I
feel like maybe the only guy who could
maybe give him a problem is the Drago
looking dude oh the Russian dude what's
the name he was the replacement for this
fight I forgot his name [__] he's the
one that knocked out tattoo ibasa right
yeah he knocked out titoivasa he smoked
Derrick Lewis in like 20 seconds yeah
and he knocked all these guys out quick
Sergey Pavlich yeah he's a he's a scary
[__] I saw that fool's
highlights he's [__] frightening as
[__] he's super scary I think he he
probably could have took a tanganu yeah
because I think so too because he
actually has wrestling too so I think he
would have [__] him and got him but I
think like his matchup against Jon Jones
might be interesting but I don't even
know if Jon Jones is gonna like mess
around with that if Jon Jones [__]
fights Stipe he could just retire after
that I think he's going yeah and then
just sail off into the sunset and he
just retires as the greatest of all time
how much cocaine do you think he did the
night he won oh he did it off of [__]
his big ass wife's face
first of all I had no idea how the
gigantic his wife was she's tall woman
how big is she I don't know if have you
seen the anime Attack on Titan
she looks like one of those [__]
Titans yes I was shook there's a
specific Titan that she actually looks
like and I I was shook pull it up side
by side again
hey no disrespect to I'm pretty sure
she's a lovely lady yeah you know shout
outs I'm not trying to make fun of her
I'm a little drunk hilarious [__]
hilarious hilarious but she is a tall
woman she was so his whole family
there's giant his dad I think his dad
was taller than him damn John is the
baby brother he's like the smallest one
of the whole family my whole family's
nothing but Champs dude NFL dudes right
I think they all have Super Bowl they
all have rings wow a whole family of
Champions dude that's unbelievable
that's a powerful sperm dude that's
powerful sperm are you gonna stop that
who gonna stop Jon Jones No One's Gonna
Stop Jones I don't even want to see Jon
Jones lose because like I'll tell you
this in my mind I mean okay so people
were bringing up once again on Twitter
like who's the greatest of all time and
they were debating like khabib or Jon
Jones
I think once you get two belts that
greatest of all time thing puts hubby
bow right because even for Daniel
Cormier I put Daniel Cormier above Habib
because of the level of competition yeah
I think people always forget about that
right so when I said when I saw Habib
retire I put him as like goat right yeah
because I saw what he was doing to
he just was just a moment No One's Gonna
beat him and I feel like right now he's
still 155 champ I think he was he was I
what I will say about khabib though
you're I think you're right about the
competition but I think round for round
he was probably like two ounces
the most dominant dude was probably
could be um but I see what you're saying
you're right Daniel Cormier way more
competition Jon Jones for sure way more
competition as well and it's in the
fashion that
that's how much they won but they also I
the reason why I put Daniel Cormier
above Jon Jones for now is because John
because Daniel Cormier won the belt also
pretty easy yeah against he knocked him
the [__] out yeah and then on top of
that he defended it so once Jon Jones
defends his heavyweight belt then to me
is Jon Jones goat forever
yeah I think a lot of people will say
they'll take Jon Jones out just because
the PED stuff yeah but even Daniel
Cormier says it too like if he didn't do
the PED he's still bro he still would
have been good like he's go yeah he's
he's the craziest specimen we've ever
seen fight like across the board across
Generations resume title defenses I
don't even like the guy I think he's a
terrible person but my favorite thing he
did was hit that pregnant lady with the
car yeah
he's ever had
that's his best way if he runs back and
grabs cash out of the car and then
leaves again like dude you are and they
just found booze and condoms in there
like Magnums in a bottle of vodka oh
he's a Savage
absolute it's like 1 p.m in the day like
what the [__] are you doing dude Anthony
Smith said something very interesting
when he was talking when he was
analyzing Jon Jones he goes When I Was
preparing for the Jon Jones fight
the reason why he felt that he couldn't
do anything was because Jon Jones was
coasting through the fight so he wasn't
bringing it to him so Anthony Smith's
plan with his team was to counter and
look for those holes in openings if Jon
Jones was going to come at him but
because Jon Jones was just kind of
playing with his food he just kind of
kept the distance and he kept piecing
him up from the outside I just kept
kicking the [__] out of his knees
exactly so he said he didn't expect that
because his team was so worried about
his [__] reach because he has like
the longest reach even in heavyweight
yeah that they didn't think about his
legs and so he just kept kicking him up
the middle [__] to his legs started
obliterating him so it's weird with Jon
Jones because what's the hole in his
game you're gonna take him down no
Daniel cormie took him down once and it
took him five [__] rounds to do that
[__] yes Daniel Cormier yeah so I don't
unders I don't I'm trying to figure out
who's gonna be the one to Dethrone him
and if he does get dethroned I think the
only reason why is because he's getting
old I I don't think anyone in the UFC
right now even like I'm like powerful
pound he's the best guy
and it hurts me to say it but it's true
yeah I think it's he's the guy no one's
beating that dude she talk about [__]
um if you guys don't know chefchenko
also a reigning champ who hasn't lost in
how many years it's been forever
a lot of people thought she didn't look
that good against Talia Santos her last
fight some people were like oh she
probably could have won that maybe
depending how it goes but it was really
cool to see Alexa
you must be happy Mexican boy yeah yeah
that's right now well technically
technically three because you have
[__] internet channel uh yeah
Rodriguez
you're right yeah so you got three right
now Mexico's [__] killing it right
they are killing it it's cool that like
certain like countries like Africa had
their thing for a while like without
Mexico yeah and it's like everyone has
their turn like Brazil
um who's the who's the champion [__]
your ears the vulcanovsky dude you're
gonna fight vulc next he has to fight
vulc next
Folk's an animal though he beat the [__]
I think Josh I'm a dude Josh Emmett yeah
you watch that yeah yeah yeah yeah the
limping [__] out of him yeah dude yeah
he's a [__] animal that was I I
thought he owed him money the way he was
[__] him up he [__] him up in the
most creative [__] way possible too
his strikes were so creative and weird
yeah he's super creative yeah you're
like every time he fights now I think
even more so he just doesn't give a [__]
about getting taken down he's like yeah
I'll do a 360 spin kick to your face and
land it and then like a little back
elbow out of nowhere like the setups are
crazy and then the way he off his back
he's like violent off his back so it's
like dude that's a weird thing he's
gonna give problems he's gonna give
problems to Volk I think I think
anywhere he goes like walcasta he has to
be on his game to be yair yeah folks one
of his advantages to speed yeah he's
faster than him yeah so I think that was
the weird thing that um uh Josh Emmett
couldn't adjust to was he could see the
left kick coming but it was so fast he
couldn't do [__] about it yeah he just
couldn't do [__] about it it was just
too quick I couldn't as a viewer I
couldn't tell when he was going to kick
yeah you know what I mean so we're
watching from the outside I'm like what
the [__] did he just kick it was so fast
yeah and I imagine like yeah you're one
of those guys who you spar with and he
stands in front of you and you're just
scared because you don't know what the
[__] he's gonna do yeah you know and
then I felt that energy from Josh Emmett
while they were fighting and then all of
a sudden he just lands the crazy [__]
and he just kicking with the body he
doesn't even care bro he's like closing
his eyes throwing body kicks and just
getting it just it just hurts bro his
whole [__] side was all red Josh is
on every steroid possible that feels a
gynecomastia or whatever the [__] that
[__] is was ridiculous he's got the
heaviest dude he had some heavy bees on
him yeah lumps on those [__] titties
he what he raised his hands and I just
saw these two [__] huge lumps on his
nipple which was there from the previous
fight and they got bigger this fool is
on all the ruins percentage-wise how how
many fighters do you think are taking
roids like how many people do you think
at least half you think more than 50 or
50 at least 50 oh bro I have no idea I
think I think because of usada it it
does
you have to be really good at how you do
your steroids like for instance the the
Jitsu Federation ibjjf or something
steroids is like rampant and Jutsu the
Pat I think they did steroid testing I
think you saw that came in and the dead
you saw they did testing for the last
tournament like five of the biggest
names just got popped for steroids and
they're like you're still competing go
ahead yeah I don't know what the band
like details are but they I think they
have to like stop competing for a little
bit but it just names where you're like
oh [__] this guy wasn't oh yeah duh yeah
but it's just that means Ryan can't
compete in that [__] right because I
don't think he does though because it's
like a nogi it's like a
[Music]
he openly States he's on steroids he
does yeah phone right look at that guy
bro I mean yeah he's yoked but I know he
was just out there like yeah I'd be
doing steroids yeah well he goes like
well I don't like not do it that's how
they do it now yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't like what the [__] dude that feels
[__] yeah it's bigger than he was in
the UFC he looked like a ninja turtle
dude yeah when he fought Gordon Ryan
yeah his traps had a little turtle show
how do you choke somebody out like that
there's no neck to choke out yeah how do
you wrap your arms around you gotta be
Gordon Ryan and Chuck that foil that
[__] is [__] crazy man he's one of
the only people that actually made
people interested in uh Jiu Jitsu yeah
now everybody's doing everybody does Jiu
Jitsu now dude now I'm scared yeah now
I'm so scared so you gotta be careful
everyone's gonna be butt scooting dude
butt scooting
one of my favorite things to watch I
know this is [__] up because I love
Jiu Jitsu but watching Jiu Jitsu guys
get knocked out like there's like a
whole compilation you could look at look
at it because they forget that they're
striking in real life yeah yeah and so
they'll get face stomped oh they're
getting like kicked in the head yeah
because they're just like on their back
like this and then you see a guy just
stomp their faces oh I forgot I'm not in
a ghee yeah you're in on the streets and
when your head goes off concrete it's
different yeah or that there's multiple
people exactly you're getting jumped dog
don't be on your dog
[Music]
get your buddies a [__] so once it
goes past one-on-one you're pretty much
[__] You Gotta Be You gotta be able to
[__] strike you gotta do it all
though honestly like yeah the grand
scheme of things like because there's
some juicy guys like they'll do MMA for
the first time and they're like oh my
god do you remember when we were at the
at the Ron fight and that random drunk
Asian guy came up to me no I wasn't
there I watched it I watched that fight
was it you who the [__] was next to me
but some other it was some other kind of
man it was other some kooky ass fighter
but we were I was uh watching Ron fight
right and we were chilling and this one
random Asian dude who's like a fan he
was drunk by the way he comes up he goes
oh I saw you were doing kickboxing stuff
like hey cool he goes but I do Jujitsu
I'll [__] choke your ass out that's
wild when I stopped thank God I forgot
who I was around but the dude it wasn't
you it was the mother I think it was
John but the John you know this guy's
big he goes what'd you say cause I'm
just [__] around like yes right I'm
with him he'll kill you but what the
weirdest thing to say to me yeah you
know what I mean some people are [__]
idiots weird also you don't want to
impress you dude these guys are all
fighters they'll kill you they'll
literally kill you and I'm like I'm with
him I literally John handling for me
real quick
what the what the [__] was that about
I'm gonna start going to Jiu-Jitsu gyms
like oh you do Jitsu well I do
kickboxing I'll knock your ass out yeah
if you [__] go on your back or grab
me you're gay
I'm not gonna I'm not oh grappling man
you're gonna kiss me to death beat my
ass but turns out gay yeah yeah yeah
oh that's right yeah but that was so
weird that guy he just [__] threaten
me I thought that was the weirdest thing
that has ever happened this is dumb dude
[__] dumb insecure dude you weren't
impressed by that no I was turned on
look down
I [__] sucked his dick you shut it up
but there's another big fight coming up
that we should talk about oh Leon
Edwards
who you got why you got them what's
going on I grew up in the streets oh
[__] that's kamaru my boy
I got
roasted marshmallows [__] opening up
about his heart uh I put I listen
I think uzman is going to obliterate
Leon Edwards I only go by this based on
human motivation right yeah I think that
Usman is such a high level [__]
narcissist in the best way possible when
it comes to fighting that he [__] with
himself so much he cannot live with
himself if he loses again that's how I
feel about Usman Usman doesn't take
likely to losses right it eats him up
every [__] day Usman the guy who was
posting non-stop on his Instagram has
barely posted in the last [__] year
or so ever since he lost to [__] Leon
Edwards
um I think he's preparing for [__]
war and I don't think he's gonna lose
really you don't think Leon's gonna be
ready bro I think Leon is going to try
to get ready but I think a motivated
Usman is frightened well also too if you
watch the last fight I mean uzman's
beating him the whole time that was
uzman's fight
until the very end yeah the biggest
thing that Usman isn't going to allow
Leon to do and it was the biggest
mistake that he made in that last round
is give him space for striking I think
he's gonna smother him and he's not
going to allow for that for him to catch
his rhythm and I think he's going to
decisively beat his ass yeah it's going
to be interesting to see how he
overcomes that mental obstacle because
there's always that mental obstacle like
getting knocked the [__] out but I think
Usman you're right is mentally crazy and
strong enough to overcome that obstacle
because people woke up in wakanda dude
that's who got kicked so [__] hard he
ate the flower and he woke up in that
[__] mystical World The ancestral
plan for the ancestral place in the
purple world he was in that purple world
that fool got knocked out where his eyes
were opened up bro that was crazy that
fool said he woke up in the ambulance
you know that yeah he didn't know that
20 minutes later yeah he had no idea
that he was knocked out until he was in
the ambulance that's [__] insane dude
I think there could be an argument there
where the second fight Usman was kind of
like in cruise control almost time right
he was in control most of the fight but
I'll give it to Leon like every time
because I just rewatched it this morning
um every time Usman took him down
Leon was working right back up he was
right there the whole time like he there
was for for somebody who was getting
beat that badly especially after like
the second third yeah fourth rounds to
take a beating like that and just keep
getting back up like he still had really
good Pockets he took him down too I just
remembered that yeah he took his back
and was like that change of the game
right he mounted him and you're like oh
[__] Leon has more of a threatening
ground game in a lot of ways than than
Usman because Usman can hold you down
but if you're Leon and you're working
your way back up who's not necessarily
like a Grappler like
then we have to question usman's ability
to like pin someone down and hold him
for a long period of time yeah because
he's throwing ground and pound but I was
like man if if Usman just starts
throwing up a little more submission
threats that can change the game because
the only thing who's uh Leon's worried
about is eating a couple punches and
then coming back up to his feet against
the cage and that was the whole time so
it's like I'm really curious to see how
that's going to be especially when
they're fighting at the O2 Arena in
London right because that crowd is
that's right they're fighting on UK soil
and he's a he's he Leon speaks funny you
hear him talk about you got a British
accent but let me tell you something
that for Leon whenever he's on the mic
can we get a [__] bouncy ball with
some translations what the [__] is he
saying it's not even his UK accent he
mumbles yeah he's a he's terrible on the
money he's like he's [__] UK Stipe
miocic hey bro you didn't like his you
don't like his post fight interview when
he won he said boom headshot dead that's
what he said anything I understood
though the only thing I understand oh
man shot that you know what brother
foreign
nobody ever give him a mic ever again
dude yeah for real this fool [__] up
his bag so bad you have [__] Megan
olivi interviewing him saying giving him
good layup questions yeah and he goes I
don't know
so what do you think is like John's
weakness you know I
um I'm a fight
that's it Stephen this is why the UFC
doesn't give a [__] about you yeah like
say something you and you you call that
a layout bro what are Jon Jones
weaknesses that is a lake after a fight
like that what would you say oh fine
fine I'm I'm steeping mitches but I can
speak English go ahead after watching
Jon Jones fight what kind of weaknesses
do you think he has in your upcoming he
hasn't fought me yet I'll obliterate him
I am the best heavyweight in this
Division and I am considered the
heavyweight goat if he wants that title
he has to come through me first you
haven't seen [__] yet that's pretty good
that was pretty good he went against
Cyril God he has absolutely zero
wrestling what did you think was going
to happen do you think he's gonna do
that to me I wrestle [__] and gone
onto the floor in our first fight yeah
the second fight I made a mistake
because I thought I clipped him and he
clipped me right back that would never
happen again Jon Jones would die by me
I'm gonna show him where the truth
somebody works for Stipe though so let
me do it like how stupid
what kind of holes do you see in Jon
Jones game
hey how good is that huh dude one time
they interviewed him and his his throat
was already like shot like
I liked was old interviews I
think
that sounds like Don Vito
Bros
I want to see an interview with him in
the Mutombo the two voices in the
history [__] give that man lotion on
his vocal cords Jesus Christ man it's
either dust coming out of his mouth this
that fool is pissing me off in that
[__] interview because he just wasn't
saying he goes
that's what it sounds [__] alien
language over here
[Laughter]
foreign
ER I appreciate you but Jesus Christ
dude you need a translator [__] man
pissed me off speech therapist he needs
a speech therapist some dog
a glass of water we'll start with that
yeah let's start with a glass of water
one of the funniest things that I ever
saw so not it was in this fight but it
was the previous fight before that there
was this young chubby little Thai girl
did you see her yeah [__] striking
clinic right and then her translator was
a white girl that spoke Thai that [__]
was hella funny I couldn't stop laughing
I've never seen that dude watch that
interview and it was like oh this is
true representation here because there
was a random she looked like a Mormon
lady and she was in her corner and I'm
like what the [__] that's one of her
coaches yeah and it turned out to be her
translator and then she comes out you
see this she looks like a Puritan she
comes out and she's speaking Thai all of
a sudden this white girl yeah
I'm ladybug
I was [__] shook dude I don't know
where the [__] they found him but she
was killing it white translators that's
what they need bro yeah they need more
white translators or the white
translators that you know what I mean
the guy that speaks Portuguese and he
looks like a white guy
he looks like Ron Perlman he looks like
[__] the dude from Sons
the portuguese translator always the
best because they always translate into
motion to they don't just do it word for
word they say it as if they were saying
it uh to all like the emotional turmoil
like how sad they are dude you have to
do the Korean guys you got to be the
translator for the Korean well I would
[__] love to you
and that
guy's in the camera
hey [__] ass [__] gonna come
to your house when the [__] clock
hits midnight I'm sticking my dick in
your wife's mouth let's go yeah the
guy's like I never said that
I never said a penis you worry about it
I got you I got you don't worry don't
trip what else did he say he said he's
gonna [__] find you he's gonna slash
your [__] tires take the rubber
stretch it out and choke you out with
the [__]
from New York I think you got the job
dude dude hey UFC hire me right now you
speak Korean yeah
okay let's talk about this um this
passed recently it was the Jake Paul um
and Tommy Fury fight Tommy Fury you look
good you know I watched more highlights
Tommy Fury was kind of Landing some some
good shot I don't know if he was
cracking him
yeah he was cracking the [__] he was
lighting him up here's the weird thing
about that uh a lot of like like Israel
had a son and watched the fight he
thought that Jake Paul won and listen I
actually thought that Jake Paul was
going to beat Tommy's ass me too so I
was rooting for Jake Paul Bro I look
like such an idiot because I was like
dude Jake Paul's gonna smoke Tommy yeah
and now I look like an [__] and when
I watched I watched the whole fight I
watched it three times because you know
when there's like a fighter that I
respect I always try to see what they're
looking at and I'm like you're [__]
I understand like oh excuse me you are
mentally deficient you are dumb
I've promised not to use this word I'm
trying to get out of my vernacular
apologies but idiot like I didn't really
get what adasanya was talking about yeah
what was he saying
he thought I think it's from that last
round where he hit him with the jab and
he fell over but he said that you know
Jake had some good hard hits yeah they
didn't phase him at all and then Tommy
was jabbing him the [__] up and he had a
lot more combos yeah yeah he wore the
shots worse he was constantly on his ass
like Landing points constantly
throughout the all the rounds like dude
connect Tommy will come back with six or
seven more shots and they weren't
Landing in his guard he was hitting him
with all the openings so I was shook
that it went to it was a split decision
I thought decisively taught me well yeah
it wasn't even close yeah same so but
it's like Jake's the money you know what
I mean boxing's we all know it's [__]
corrupt so but uh yeah and to me too it
seemed like Tommy Fury he's was like
definitely won that [__] fight you
know he beat his ass dog yeah he beat
his [__] ass man he lit him up Tommy
Fury's dad is hilarious have you seen
history
John Fury's [__] hilarious amazing
too isn't it I told you a YouTuber let
me tell you something what he's going to
do he's gonna go find your woman Bend
Rubber and smash it from the back he
literally said that that sounds like a
David cell promo right now he literally
think that's John Fury he literally said
David So original he just said that
earlier yeah he's going to take you from
the ass
so you're speaking English
like a d swine
did he really say that he literally said
that I'm gonna look that [__] up after
John Fury he's a wah man though in the
gypsies the gypsies don't give up bro
him and Tyson look the same they look
exactly the same and then Jake Paul just
has like he looks like Mike Wazowski
he's got like the longest arms I've ever
seen on a person but it's like you just
like oh that guy's on love Island that's
that's why I think of him and he he's
not gonna have any more fights like
who's gonna fight him now yeah people
also forget too with uh Tommy Fury he's
only 23. yeah he's a baby he's a young
lad yeah they say over there young
ladies I think he's young he's younger
than Jake Paul is he really yeah I think
Jake Paul's like 24 25 so he's like a
couple years younger then he has the
tutelage of his brother that's [__]
amazing dude exactly that's like a worm
so it doesn't come out I can't spell it
though impact
there you go
this guy with a jack off for one month
so I mean he's smart you don't know the
words yeah but when I was watching that
[__] it was uh it was interesting
because I really thought that Jake Paul
was going to win and then afterwards
here's the funny thing about that [__]
like
everybody was wondering how good Jake
Paul's boxing was right and I think
because he promos himself so well I kind
of got caught into the hype a little bit
but then like when you look at that
fight from a low-level Pro
like Tommy Fury and he is very low level
there are he's going to get destroyed by
so many Pros in boxing right but once
again he's young and he just started I
assume that Jake Paul was on his level
and Jake Paul was not Jake Paul is at
Best of mid-level amateur only because
and there was somebody who wrote this to
me on Twitter he goes because that guy
was boxing or whatever he goes the
biggest problem that Jake Paul has is
that most amateurs when they come in to
fight at the level that he has has
already a hundred matches he has no
rounds so Jake Paul's ability to get
better is only based on his money and
the trainers that he has but there's
something that he doesn't have which is
experience and experience speaks for
everything sure so at least Tommy Fury
has like eight six six or eight Pro
matches so he has a lot of competition
under his belt and he's done amateur
matches I believe as well so that's why
Jake he's like his footwork is terrible
yeah and everybody has the biggest part
and I suppose especially too it's like
yeah he has a big right hand but if he
can't get in position to land those
shots on someone who's like pretty good
defensively he's gonna have a lot of
like hard time and that's what happen
with Tommy fury like anytime he lands
that big shot is because the guy that
he's fighting they stand right in front
of him in that 50 50 position and
they're like all right let's go that's
how he knocked out Tyron Woodley he's
still there feet planted yeah and it's
like you obviously like you shouldn't
you have to show him respect and not
like be right up in front of him like
all right let's [__] throw yeah no
you're giving him you're giving him an
out essentially the same with Anderson
Silva right he started he was winning
rounds and he kind of got Reckless
got sat down and then in that 50 50
position it's like ah you can't be you
can't be doing that with someone who's
younger than you who's
a lot bigger has a big punching power so
it's like
people I think question like how did
that even happen but I think that's
that's exactly this is the first time
Jay Paul has fought somebody who wasn't
retired in their sport yeah right you
know what I mean exactly yeah that's
actually his age that his his size
nobody he thought was his size yeah and
and also dedicated to that sport like
this is the first boxer boxer he bought
you know what I mean Joe Rogan sucks
Jake Paul's dick a lot too he's like
he's legit he's amazing and I'm like
I understand what Joe means I think
people don't give Jake Paul enough
credit sometimes right but now people
are overestimating him they got to bring
him down because there's I mean how many
Pros that we know that can murder Jake
Paul yeah yeah like who was the guy that
was going to fight him uh Hassan dude
what was the name Hassan Jr Rahman yeah
son of a legend if he fought Jake Paul
because they were supposed to fight
earlier and he killed him oh man it
would have been a completely different
fight like I think that would have like
lowered the stock it would have upgraded
him oh yeah I mean in this way it's kind
of smart though he made all his money he
then he finally like was like all right
I'll do the real test he lost lost a lot
of stock but like look at all the money
he's already he's already I don't think
he's really gonna try to be a pro he's
on the best path by far yeah obviously
like for your wife he did the right
thing I I think this is this kind of
goes
so when the Hassan Rahman Jr thing
happened right everybody was saying that
oh if Hassan yo if you really wanted to
fight him you would have lost the weight
right and then Hassan was still cutting
the weight at the fight time I think he
was only like two pounds over two or
three pounds over right which is really
really [__] close but then Jake Paul
wrote all these weird stipulations to
make sure that fight didn't happen yeah
and that's what a lot of people don't
give credit to like Jake Paul did not
want to fight Hassan Rahman Jr at all he
just wanted I wouldn't know either if I
was him I'd be like yeah because his
son's an actual heavyweight he's fought
at light heavyweight but only for a few
but he's he's a big boy also too he's
actually not bad he's actually he's very
nice he's nice jab is decent too so if
you thought [__] Tommy was gonna jab
his face and son would have obliterated
him and you could see it more seasoned
vet way more seasoned he's still like a
beginner like he's still like a quote
unquote a low-level Pro but he's still
like wait he's bigger than Jake Paul
he's got way more experience like I
think he would he would have been an
ugly knife for him and he's way more
powerful than too Hassan Rahman hits
hard dude damn if you see the the small
little spawning match that um that Jake
Paul had which was only like a year ago
right it was like night and day like how
much better Hassan was and Hassan was
only allowed to use his jab and he was
beating the living [__] out of Jake he's
tagging him just tagging him and having
him running around yeah so like it just
would have been a really bad luck so
smart on Jake did not want to fight him
but if Hassan by chance just I don't
know how he did it if he got that if he
got his weight in Hassan would have
killed him like it would have been bad I
think he would have been knocked out
so very good on him and Hassan wants to
fight I'm sure yeah he wants that payday
[__] yeah but he's going why not fight
KSI Next Time Jake Paul you think so
probably that's probably the next fight
to make unless they do a rematch with
Tommy Fury I don't know if they're going
to want to watch it Logan Paul wants to
fight uh yeah that that I saw that clip
of him like grabbing the microphone I
didn't even know it was in between like
rounds where he goes Tommy he goes Tommy
Fury you're a [__] your whole family is
a bunch of [__]
in between rounds yeah I guess it was uh
like someone who's interviewing him uh
and then he grabbed it and started
yelling it was so corny yeah it was very
[__] cool even the guy was like oh
dude
you have your Prime stuff you have
millions of dollars dude beat WWE
because he's so good at that Logan
Paul's very good at the WWE yeah you
know what the weird thing is like with
him like he don't watch WWE Bros
I'm a real man this guy's never even
seen a Royal Rumble
you don't think I know about my [__]
Rikishi's all right
yeah dude what Arrow was he in uh-huh
what Arrow was he in there you idiot
which was sounds like he doesn't know
sounds like he doesn't know give me four
wrestlers that are wrestling right now
aside from [__] Logan Paul you [__]
fake [__] okay you want to hear some
[__] yeah I'm a [__] embarrass you so
bad dude no if you say this yourself
you're gonna embarrass yourself so go
ahead
I'm gonna set you up for all the WWE
heads in there
[__] Logan Paul I said that Logan
Paul all right Bad Bunny Bad Bunny Bad
Bunny he did he did that he did WWE is
he on the roster right you wouldn't
[__] know I don't know if you're on
the roster but he did a match okay first
of all any man that listen to Bad money
is a [__] go ahead that's that's
[__] girl music dude hey his I was
shaking my thing at his concert I bet
you were [__] go ahead I liked it you
went to his concert yeah okay
this one was a Playboy bunny tattoo on
the tip of the [__]
I showed you that in confidence
Donald Trump okay
okay he's on the WWE Roman Reigns
amazing
you know that's a wrestler I even I know
Roman Roman Reigns okay dude and who
[__]
The Heartbreak Kid Sean Michaels
that's even what you think I'm cute you
know I'm sexy that's the best song ever
anyways yeah so switching music
subscribers this guy at all these guys
are fat you just got voted dude as they
often are sometimes come sign up with
Nick just learn how to get fatter you
gotta talk about profession we talk
about WWE bro I am talking about your
friends both those things are fake as
[__]
damn brother yeah Dave is so quick dude
a Royal Rumble though back in the day
was the [__] oh my God yeah because they
were gone they would get a shot at the
WWE Championship yeah come on Rikishi
was a [__] Gold Dust you remember
Goldust dude he was a rapist was he well
I mean like
his character he would like [__] like
touch dudes dicks and [__] oh yeah he
was like that was like his Persona was
like oh my God I don't mean I was like I
just got I was like no it was like
somebody was like let's have a character
who's like a rapist yeah and these are
special fondling dude's dick I want to
hear the pitch of that [__] and say hey
this is what I'm doing just a ball of
gold
[__] sexually harass everybody yeah
Gold Dust epic was like that's genius
dude there was one dude special move it
was this big black dude he would wear
like this kind of like
silky clothes they were like pajamas and
he would his special move was he would
lay you down on your stomach and he
would just dry hump the [__] out of your
ass like he would literally just do like
the worm buddy
dude WWF dude in the middle of the ring
that was like the spice Channel we
literally just dry humped the [__] out
somebody and then afterwards they had to
be like oh cause like the special move
always was like the one that got the
three count so he would like dry hump
him like five times
yeah and then when Rikishi would do his
move or he would take his fat ass and
shove it and that was I would I would
quit immediately oh yeah it's over it
I'm like you know what but you got to
sell it though well interview like a
podcast and he was talking about it
where he said that everybody hated it oh
I'm sure every all the people who had to
get that [__] done [__] hate it and
since there was certain wrestlers that
were really about it because they were
into their craft they had their head up
and they just stuck their nose straight
into that ass oh and it was like Kurt
Angle was one of those guys like he was
a performer all the way and then there
was I specifically remember this one
time where um The Rock Vince McMahon
yeah and shoved his face in that [__]
and he said that businessman before they
performed that day he goes Rikishi I
hope you wash your ass today
so his [__] booty looked like the
surface of the Moon yeah it was cottage
cheese that [__] was crazy he wasn't
worried about cellulite dogs
better probably you probably sell more
tickets and [__] dude that's some cool
movie right there dude that's some katsu
booty dude bro Hawaiian mac salad let's
go baby poke booty damn dude yeah that
was a [__] though Rikishi X-Pac the this
the D generation suck it suck it yeah
dude kids were getting the fights over
that oh dude if you did that that was
basically telling you that you [__]
their mom yeah that was a fist fight I
was like on site like someone did this
it was just like backpacks
in the second grade I got sent home dude
I'm sorry
Xbox I saw someone do it and people
started I didn't know what it meant but
I just started doing it yeah people
started I kept saying suck my dick and I
got sent home so I remember this dude in
uh in junior high his name was uh it's
called JP so JP Filipino dude he uh like
10 Filipino Japanese you know at the
time this was hot right it was just the
biggest insult ever was to call somebody
[__] right I'm trying to take it out
of my I didn't know how offensive it was
to people uh it's half half but I'd
rather just you know I'll probably just
take it out by a [__] I'll take it
out of the [__] vernacular but that
was like the thing in elementary school
you would call people [__] it was
like a big insult it's a good burn so
this dude JP he was like famously known
in junior high for making fun of people
but he wouldn't call them the r word he
would just look at you and go
which was a thing yeah yeah yeah so
that's very popular we were we this is
like the worst thing that could ever
happen to you
so there was a kid who was in class I
don't understand why he was in our class
because he was uh mentally disabled but
he was in her class at the time
um and then it was during it was a
geometry
it was geometry it was in junior high we
were in geometry in eighth grade and he
insulted somebody in the class by doing
the classic JP thing which was which
made us laugh but didn't make Mr Fuentes
laugh so he looks at the kid and he goes
you freaking [__] like that and then
Mr Fuentes catches him and he makes him
go up to the front of the class and he
goes you need to apologize to everybody
right now because that is unacceptable
and then there was a kid who was
mentally disabled yeah and he made him
apologized to him from the class and
then JP was crying
I'm so sorry
I didn't mean to be what's the word
and he was bawling wow and it didn't
matter because guess what happened
during a [__] break my [__] went
straight back to it
a little cried apologizing right at the
class he went right back to it again
damn bro that was no shame no shame in
this game for Jeep if you don't like
kids in elementary school one of my
buddy was telling me that you know how
when we were kids we used to make like
gay jokes they still do that now yeah I
thought I thought it would never get old
I guess it doesn't get old it'll never
get old so um all these jokes are
evergreen I feel like it the more they
try to suppress it too the more that's
the fun it makes it funnier it's more
charged my uh my buddy's nephew was in
school and you know um growing up they
would just Pat him in the butt if he
does good things so he's like in third
grade and one of his friends did they're
playing basketball or some whatever
Sport and he made a shot or whatever he
doesn't know he passed his friend in the
butt and he said his friend turned
around and looked at him he goes hey
that's gay
[Laughter]
it's not gay he goes no
that's gay you can't you can't touch my
butt that's gay he goes That's not gay
he goes my my uncle does that to me all
the time he goes your uncle's gay
but he legitimate shook yeah but I guess
they still roast you for doing stuff
like that in elementary holy [__] yeah
never change it'll never change man we
got to keep it around forever you got to
keep it and I think it's just gonna it
just the way humans are dude yeah it's
just a human thing it's funny it's
harmless I don't I'd be so funny dude I
my kid's gay
I just I I'm like one role in the house
it's like listen I accept that you're
gay that's perfectly fine but you gotta
let me make fun of you though yeah yeah
jokes YouTube jokes yeah yeah you gotta
build a thick skin I think any type of
situation whatever you are whatever's
going on we're cracking jokes hard jokes
like we're family dude it doesn't matter
dude every [__] Barbecue on my look
Peter wants a hot dog
of course because you're not gonna chew
it either you throat [__]
you have to you have to let me that
means I love you I must if I didn't do
that that means I don't love you kidding
yeah it's a must you know that's you
that's your love language you like to
[__] roast people all the [__]
time dude before we were filming you
were talking about how people like would
get like some people they don't know
that and they don't they don't
communicate like that they get their
feelings hurt dude so we I went to um
APL Adam Perry Lane barbecue spot so
crazy and then my buddy we're gonna go
by the way oh okay when I come back from
Mexico I'm going to Mexico this weekend
you are yeah for a wedding damn dude
where in Mexico you know she's cracking
off so that's what they literally was
just an advisory like for specific
states don't go to Mexico what state are
you going to let me tell you I don't
know it's like it's a resort where in
it's a long ass name I've never heard of
it though okay but
don't go away that's one of them you're
not supposed to go yeah but so
number one listen this is not my friend
this is the lady's friend right okay
okay she's not gonna listen to this
podcast but I [__] hate your guts
because this [__] sets up this
wedding
doesn't tell us how to book the [__]
hotel the resort right yeah me don't no
habla Espanol
my playing glass yeah
yeah you're making it happen
yeah the name of the hotel you don't
call her up trying to book this [__] for
a week and my lady calls her up it's
like hey we can't book this because
nobody speaks English over there and for
some reason at the resort it's hard to
get a hold of anybody
so how did you do this they're like oh
well my husband he's Mexican and his
family just did all for us hey [__] how
about you do it for your [__] guests
too yeah like a decent host yeah so
everybody's struggling to get a booking
and then we couldn't get it so she just
I was like oh I'll tell them to do it
yeah no [__] dummy so and on top of that
too right because there's like some
obscure Place dude yeah okay the only
flights it's so we're flying in on
Friday right guess when the next
available flight is Tuesday oh man
dude you're going to some [__] up ass
spot so now I'm like I don't want to go
to this because number one me scared of
Mexico yeah yeah bro so on the news if
you guys don't know somebody just got
chopped the [__] up yeah yeah a couple
of Americans got kidnapped a couple of
them got killed away well bad sign
number one though is that usually at
Resorts people can speak the American
tourists that's their money yeah so the
fact that no one knows how to speak
English at that Resort is you're gonna
go into a Hut dude you're going to like
a straw Three Little Pigs yeah made in a
straw ass Hut okay don't say this yeah
yeah you don't even know what [__]
city is like honestly some dudes got
kidnapped and killed and then I just
thought today they were like yo don't go
to these states specific there's like
five states specifically but I mean
Mexico's kind of [__] popular that's
what I'm saying man and I don't know
what it is about my lady but she out
here living in a [__] in la la land
yeah and I've been to Mexico a couple of
times I've been to some CDs areas let me
tell you something oh a little racist
towards people that look like us we
stick out bro we stick out like blatant
racism okay because it's not my country
just chinos they call you chinos which
is Chinese you're all Chinese
I think I'm Chinese but I remember
walking in Tijuana right and obviously
I'm going through for missionary work
the [__] would just come up to me
[Applause]
unwarranted yeah for no reason I'm just
walking by
we were in Playa del Carmen right so
we're walking around very touristy area
you might see some chinos over there but
these two guys were walking they're
locals I don't know why they did this
but they just pointed at me and they go
Tito you may hold their bellies and
start laughing and I go what the [__]
dude and that happened the whole time I
was there we went to a resort in Cancun
and it was like a it was like one of
those like day Excursion things right
one of the guys was the Lifeguard
me and Tiff are standing there getting
ready to hop on the zip line or whatever
he looks at Tiff in Spanish and goes
where are you from
she goes oh I'm from L.A she's like oh
very cool and then he looks at her and
he goes what about you are you from
North Korea or China those are the only
two options I got and I go I'm from
China and he goes cool you know what's
actually very Progressive of that guy to
know Korea though yeah
it's just everyone's trying it's like
Chinos that's just with chinos yeah and
what's funny is like people think that
like only like white people can be
racist but like dude everyone's racist
everyone can be racist uh I remember I
was watching a soccer game Mexico lost
to Japan so Japan is happening Spanish
is how you say Japanese people my uncle
was pissed he's like [__] chinos it
says Japan on the screen
like dude they're Japanese he's like I
know all those finches chinos like it
just that's just what it is this is what
it is like I don't know what word you're
saying
it's the fact that guy knew about Korea
is actually that guy's ahead of the
curve yeah he said that he wasn't even
making a joke yeah he was like yeah
North Korea or China North Korean or
from Japan and he's like he's going to
be impressed yeah I know they don't get
very many North Korean tourists you know
what I mean so the fact that he pulled
that out of his hat I was like I feel
like you're making fun of me I feel like
you're making fun of me he's like hey
how come you won't open your eyes
look at these you know the funny thing
is like when Mexican people do that I'm
like your eyes are just like mine yeah
yeah there's there's honestly a lot of
Asian looking yeah
like Maddie how many Mexican people do
you know their nickname is chinito yeah
exactly that's the thing yeah you know
it's a little Asian hey yeah
yeah little
[Laughter]
will be like pulling back their eyes I'm
like hey dog it already looks like that
yeah you ain't got to do it you actually
got to look like me bro legit a lot of
Latinos look Asians [__] like mad Asian
adjacent dude they are dude my mom loves
Mexican food you know why because it's
almost like the same type of ingredients
she loves [__] uh menudo ah because
it has all like the tripod [__] like
that my mom [__] loves that [__] wow
and now you have like all the Mexican
people going to Korean barbecue and
making and bringing tortilla presses
yeah
yeah smart as [__] dog it's right there
and they make our food better than we do
yeah you see that [__] in Tai Fung
within Tai fun the Taiwanese spot it's
all Mexican dudes rolling out the phone
in tobacco oh yeah they're like he's a
[__] thing they're doing 18 folds in
the kitchen it's always Latino dudes in
the kitchen dude I don't know how they
learn that [__] so [__] fast too easy
bro yeah like we're willing to work yeah
unlike you Americans and that's why they
get all the time and they take pride in
working too yeah like like that that's
the thing is like working in restaurants
like if you want to get like one of
those dudes respect it's just work hard
and then they that's that's all that's
what they respect that's they take pride
in the fact that they work hard that's
it they're like just about hard work
they're like dude he's like I work 47
hours a day dog what about what about
you yeah it's about you and but if you
bust your ass they're like hey you're
cool that's funny anytime I worked at a
restaurant job the bus boys especially
if you work the morning shift they're
like they wrap up and they go to their
night job always like all the all the
dudes that worked in the back in the
kitchen that always had another job
they're working throughout the day two
jobs a day I know a guy that works seven
doubles he never literally doesn't have
a day off or a night off he works seven
days straight doubles yeah what do you
do look like yeah he just he just works
constantly he's like he's not even he's
just like an element of the world that
just works
dude it's like a gaseous cleaning lady
she's from Honduras she's four foot ten
amazing [__] I've seen her lift the
refrigerator by herself
she's [__] a mate and I'll tell you
this not to [__] on my own people right
mixing people a lot more honest than
Asian people especially when it comes to
like cleaning [__] so like this lady I
[__] love her her name is ritzy right
she's Honduran
[__] love her to death
does her job does it really [__] well
she doesn't ever try to dip us we get uh
we had like Asian cleaning people before
[__] come in hey them the next week
it actually is a 140 dollars and I'm
like no been paying 120 for the past
like I don't know six seven months no
you still 20 from me 140. I'm like okay
here's 140. right next week give them
140. you you're short thirty dollars
170. [__] you guys yeah this is why you
live in a communist country and I hate
you I [__] hate you every [__]
Asian cleaner did that [__] to us damn
the Mexican ladies [__] Swedish [__]
occasionally bring us food for some
goddamn give you a deal that's nice you
know what I mean you food yeah that's
food for some [__] reasons
that's nice I don't get it yeah you know
but I [__] love it [__] yeah and I
never get that from the Asian cleaners
tips brown family is way cooler than my
yellow family dude they're just by far
away
that should sound racist yeah what they
are though like they're just so much
sweeter they're just so much more like
like they're just like I feel like they
care about me you know they could just
be nice people because there's obviously
[__] bags oh of course of course but
even that like just like the way you
walk in the door they're just already
offering like you're just so part of the
culture but in my family it's the
complete opposite maybe I have a bad
family I feel like I I like maybe it's a
bad family your mom's always been cool
though everyone's your house she's
talking [__] all day that was always
cool too to me I mean they were always
chilling with me yeah because you know
you're a good guy they like you we would
like talk [__] they crack jokes yeah
that's that's how they get along sisters
in the corner being a lesbian I know
what you mean though hey [__] Latino
warmth is different though that's what I
mean yeah it's nothing like Asian warmth
there is no Asian warmth I remember just
like going to like the Mexican homies
houses they'd be giving kisses on the
cheek and [__] I'm like what the [__] is
this your mom's trying to [__] me what's
up yeah yeah man I just wasn't used to
this stuff and they're just so warm the
way they greet you yeah it's just a
little different they also incorporate
you really easy yes like anybody like
like a friend will come like I've had
friends over for like holiday parties
like if their family was out of town or
whatever and just instantly like you're
just one of the fans like you yeah come
in here I want to start like my
grandmother's shooting [__] with you
like yeah there there is that family
incorporate everything it's like time
goes by I suddenly have a thick mustache
growing up I was afraid to bring friends
home to the house because I'd feel like
if they didn't do the right sequence of
things of saying hello to my mother in a
certain way or take their shoes or
whatever the [__] she was gonna yell at
them and just like and yell at me at
once they're gone like don't you ever
bring this [__] guy to my house
because that would always happen oh wow
so we just never had people over ever oh
damn growing up
it was just a very strict unwelcoming
household yeah like it just was a sense
of like why even bother I'll just go to
my friend's house like the only
difference is is like I I know this
about like the Mexican home girls you
don't bring a boy over though yeah that
sentence you know oh for sure but if it
was a dude it was [__] different yeah
yeah you know like on some sexy [__] I
don't know what the [__] that was yeah
yeah for sure honestly 100 yeah dudes
are definitely treated a lot different
than girls yeah if you if you were a
girl and you brought a guy over you're a
[__] yeah you were a straight up poor
yeah yeah yeah [__] all the aunts are
talking [__] 100 but that's why all the
[__] Mexican girls would always do
[__] on the side because they just
[__] battle them up like this so they
were just sucking dick everywhere else
can't do that they wouldn't have done it
they let a couple of boys and then they
got to know the boys
suck [__] all the dicks all the dicks
yeah my friend told me too like was she
um she was younger she brought a boy
over and she didn't know you know she
was like oh this is like my guy friend
from elementary school and her [__]
[__] mom her aunts called her like
[__] a [__] and all sort of [__] I
think it was just like hyper religious
[__] yeah yeah it means like that's what
[__] do that's what like horse is wild
yeah very Catholic very very Catholic so
guess what that [__] they were right
because she was a hoe
self-fulfilling prophecy self-fulfilling
I mean they [__] had her like tight
like this so whenever she wanted to do
something she always had to lie to her
parents 24 7. she had to go out here and
just [__] suck that dog she never
sucked mine what the [__] did I get it I
get it you're close though probably
close you're probably close I ain't
gonna lie though I know this I shouldn't
be saying this but I was a little upset
because I remember she hooked up with
this one dude that was substantially
ugly with me okay yeah what the [__]
that's upsetting like I'm right here I'm
right in front of you I've been holding
your [__] [__] uh lunch bag all
day you ain't gonna [__] suck my dick
but you suck this guy yeah yeah what the
[__] is this guy's hideous yeah yeah I
think it was just right place at the
right time and I just wasn't there dude
damn sick that day or something yeah
missed the bus I [__] miss her
um just kidding she's hideous
I still keep tabs on her well guys
every day and classmates.com
[Laughter]
you guys could catch Nick at Nick the
ear nte strong he trains out of uh
what's it called Lionheart Jiu Jitsu
Academy if you guys are looking for
personal training the Manchester people
out there if you are really really fit
right now hit up Nick he will make sure
that you are fat as [__] by the end of
the year and trying to gain some weight
some lbs here's your boy yeah you try to
get a heart attack some [__] coronary
heart disease get you set up right hit
up Pat
patrick.t.riley Uh start harassing him
tell him to start post more content on
his ship because he never does that I
didn't show him the good and it's
[__] dumb because everybody does it
but Pat so he's a [__] idiot so uh
start harassing him a little more tell
him to stop working out and start
putting up more [__] posts about that
uh and then you catch Genie Spain every
time
I don't even post that much I'll see you
guys
next time